imitation now apparently follows you
even at a bar you're out there having
some fun you can't do politics there
either
Johnny McKay Mack a I think made
headlines yesterday after someone
torched his truck because he dared to
have a pro Trump sticker on it
Johnny first of all it's good to have
you with us I'm sorry this happened to
you is this like a normal occurrence for
Trump supporters in Washington states
obviously a very liberal state what
gives here no it's a Washington's
actually more Pro Trump than just across
the river in Portland so it's very
unusual so you what did the sticker look
like I had two stickers I had they're
both Trump 2021 says make liberals cry
again and the other one said keep
America great okay there make liberals
cry again it's really funny and you have
to get me one although I think I'll put
it on my other car so you you came out
of the bar what time at what time you
just left the car there cuz you you
stayed there late and then you came back
the next morning what happened well my
wife is at work and I was home bored so
I went to the bar to have a couple
drinks and placing a pool I was only
there for about an hour and a half I had
four beers played a couple games of pool
and left at 10:30
I took an uber home because I was
feeling it and when I went back in the
morning my truck was gone and they found
it where it was in the parking lot it
was completely torched whoever did it
the only thing I can think of is they
didn't like my the Trump bumper stickers
because they wrote the lady who
initially called 911 she told the bar
owner that it said on the front door it
said fu Trump on it and but the Scorch
burnt the other part off and all that
was left was the Trump part yeah I'm
sure it wasn't we love Trump let me burn
your truck yeah that's just that's
pretty that's a pretty logical guess I'm
really sorry this happened to you I mean
this is just
you can't put a bumper sticker on your
car you can you have to get one you have
to confuse him next time and have like
make America great and then like
visualize world peace you know
or question authority chef Sam like
liberal Greenpeace stuff and Trump stuff
then they'll be stuck and they won't
know what to do okay just do that that
will really freak him out all right and
I hope you get I hope you get a new
truck open surance covers that